hello happy Wednesday everybody pleasure
to be here I'm Eric that's David fresh
space here at GameSpot he's been with us
like two months now coming up on two
months sweet he's been handling gameplay
for us and Erin one of our kind of like
FPS gurus in the office was like hey
guess what World War three early access
is out so here we are we're checking out
early access I think it comes out this
Friday if I'm not mistaken which is like
the same day as when battlefield was
supposed to come out that's correct yeah
and this game is eerily similar in some
ways to battlefield at least like
aesthetically and things like that
totally totally even in some of its like
objectives and the game modes and stuff
it feels a lot like battlefield 4
cool why don't you take us through some
of it I know you've only been playing a
couple hours this morning because we did
have it yesterday technically but the
server's weren't up servers went up
today so bear with us as we try to you
know get through some of these games you
know for all we know some are gonna be
less populated in the others just again
because it's early access but happy to
be here with everyone and let's see how
this goes yeah totally
first thing we'll do first let's go
straight to an enemy flag and try and
get some trouble all right sounds good
to me you want to get hot yeah it's hot
what's up crime how you doing Eric how
you doing original game head thanks for
the kind words if you guys didn't know
we are live every day well every Monday
to Friday at 11 a.m. so you guys just
stop by hang out with us we play
generally you know new games games we
can preview betas alphas we're gonna be
playing something a little early
tomorrow as well should be a fun time
it's not technically a new game per se
but should be good I think the Red Dead
trailer comes out tomorrow too I think
yeah got him here we go there's got got
to all right can't that the stream can't
get any better than this is this
two-piece that we just got the ceiling
right here yeah
we hit our we hit our ceiling if you
follow the lotto at all I don't know if
anyone wanted a big one last night no
they didn't okay
they did not me and my fiancee we bought
some and and we did we definitely did
not win I wasn't sure if anyone one
because they had just announced the
numbers right I'm sure everyone's like
why I know these maps pretty cool it's
like pretty big yeah like asthma and we
had talked about it's kind of like very
battlefield I like the verticality the
verticality two FPS maps are totally
always cool are there like classes as
well yeah so they have so basically they
let me choose if I wanted to be like
from the west or east of Mission I don't
know if that actually meant anything but
they do give you a loadout for medium
light and heavy
okay so medium so let's give a light ago
real quick and see what that looks like
okay now you have a sniper okay cool
yeah it's bolt action - it's pretty
quick bolt though pretty are pretty
quick reload there right I'm kind of
used to a bunch of really slow reload
fortnight bolts so this is gonna be
interesting
ooh I like I like the sandwich like
right here yes those g29 and then the
heavies got a you ukm in an RPG ok cool
taking out vehicles and right because
there are some vehicles here oh yeah we
got a tank at a - it looks like which is
good eh - we got I'm pushing up there we
are currently playing on PC I believe
it's only on PC right now yeah
definitely the early access yeah I think
it's only on Steam though for world war
interesting to see how this game does
just because it isn't a month out like
it is out a month earlier than
battlefield and it does have a lot of
those similarities at least that
personal
we also put some gameplay up during
Gamescom because that was the first time
they ever revealed gameplay of World War
3 right it's been kind of whoa that was
a little creepy oh they got some lean
okay that lean mechanics that's cool
yeah they do yeah you can lean yeah
sweet
yeah little lean which is nice big 100
oh dude I don't have a kill cam man yeah
I can actually see what there's there's
pros and cons to kill cams I feel like
it's like the pro is like yeah you get
to know who killed you and from where
right what the con there is that you
know that guy gets revealed Yeah right
he's got a good sniper perch though I
take it you're a sniper no I actually
I'm terrible sniper I have an SMG AR
kind of guy very nice so yeah so I
definitely pulled you out of your
comfort zone by having you switch
classes that's all right I mean I wanted
to try out the heavy one anyway it's not
just similarities there's even some game
mechanics from battlefield this is true
yeah so I will see what happens I mean
like battlefield is such a kind of
established you know franchise that
totally curious if people will leave
battlefield to play this or not or maybe
they'll play both maybe they'll play
this for a month and be like oh I don't
have battlefield for the next month so I
guess I'll fill my itch and the thing is
I think it's only I don't even think
it's like a full priced game as what
Aaron said but I'm not 100% sure on that
because I don't something like 28 to 30
but right
we'd have to double check that Oh see
anything all right
oh I got hit from two different angles
yes sir
you got him down no Billy it's not free
oh now you guys are losing you guys had
four points earlier we did we did yeah
the UM yeah no but we'll be able to get
him too I just I don't know what our our
vehicles doing just kind of yeah
Karm wants to know do the weapons feel
different it's a small dev team but they
can go hardcore make each gun unique so
the weapons I mean if you play a lot of
shooters you're gonna be it's gonna feel
natural to you nothing feels too out of
place I would say um but the different
types of weapons do feel significantly
different which is cool you know so if
you have if you like more auto rifles or
if you like you know like that
bolt-action sniper and stuff the cadence
and the timing of things really do feel
a little different and I think I'm
guessing there's more like actual like
recoil and stuff yeah and they've got
some interesting things to like sir for
example if I go prone right here I can
actually roll on my stomach and kind of
like oh it's got them battlefield but
the but scooching yeah that's so weird
to me but I don't play bout it's a
suppressive fire so just he'll like
regen heal or do you actually have like
yeah geez okay I actually forgot how to
use my mecha so we're just gonna we're
gonna play a little risky so you can see
what happens okay it's gonna hard to go
oh my god I got flashbang and I saw like
three people coming up that escalator
yeah
it stared right into it
reserved boy oh yeah you're like me
you're not used to doing the peeking
well you should probably figure out what
your medkit
this is while we're at it let's see we
got a bunch of different things right
there I feel like it would be the gadget
because you can actually choose here we
go it's a gadget yeah come on you're
three okay kid yeah there you go gadget
so you actually have different options
you can choose to have a first-aid kit
the difference is but yeah I guess we'll
find out
there's also drones which is pretty neat
I had a chat how do I get out of my
truck Emer 99 says rainbow succeeds way
better it's pretty different game though
I feel like we're both succeed is more
almost a counter-strike esque where you
know like one team against another well
this also has one team against another
team but like in a smaller objective
based like map where this is like a huge
you know multi point you know massive
scale or more massive scale I guess and
way more players as well yeah for sure
John Inglish things that the recoil
needs to be last I don't know I didn't
even see like that much all right this
is a terrible spot I hope so yeah yeah
okay I do oh it's still ticking
interesting okay oh it's a timer then no
no you got an initial burst of health
and then you also got like it was also
rejoining after that I think this is I
think it's more like insurgency yeah but
this looks cleaner than insurgency to me
certain seems a little weird but I do I
guess like you're not wrong though or
rather you're right in that the the like
gameplay is similar I guess but I think
this game looks a lot nicer for whatever
it is it's really clean it's more
polished I guess yeah I'm kind of
surprised there's no like LEvolution is
there like is there any like you know
you rock it a building and it opens the
wall yeah well not that I've seen I mean
I could without an RPG just have battle
royale - I don't think so I'm actually
curious if battle royale now that it's
delayed if it'll actually ship what the
battle royale mode or not I don't I
don't know if they even said I should
look that up probably they plan on
they're gonna do they're gonna do a
battle royale they just didn't say what
exactly how exactly it would work or
what it is other than the fact that
they've just said like that do one you
know about to say you are crazy I just
want to find someone they're not just so
big I mean you are running like way
faster than I think you would to be
honest but that's fine maybe it's to
kind of you know compensate for the fact
that these maps are big but now you also
have vehicles so it's kind of like
that's true can actually get oh here we
go oh there you go you're you're on the
capture point to you this is good yeah
getting some objectives in yeah maybe
you should look behind
I can't it's not even a mounted gun it's
just like yes I guess if it's like a
seat though then yeah it would be it
makes sense that you can go all the way
though that actually is an awful seed no
no no it makes sense actually I thought
Oh buddy
three three can you not in there
I can not Oh yep grenade now is the
gadget maybe oh I have the med pack
that's what it was watch down now open
air here this is a problem you know like
back out real quick and see what this is
med pack is that for me okay
oh it's like so everyone gets
okay that might be better than the I
think it's better than the first aid
yeah I know first day it's a little bit
more selfish though it's more like the
call of duty you know like you you give
it to yourself although you can still do
it to other people but you know what I
mean you don't have to throw down the
pack and then hold it or that be more my
play style probably let's see you sorry
if I miss Chad what's the difference
from battlefield um well the buildings
aren't breaking right now yeah as we can
tell that's good and try this lean thing
I mean with the rock with it I think he
watch out if he goes oh yeah yeah and
like now that you use your med kit I'm
guessing you don't have a gun I don't
like how you just like out in the open
you're not playing tactical yeah you're
thinking like this is like COD when it's
it's like more like battlefield right
things hurt I think Chris I don't know
that for a fact
that's just what Aaron said all right I
try to double check for you guys as this
open beta no we just got early access we
got it from the developers they gave us
a key so we're able to show it off let
me see oh yeah 28 USD I think doesn't
like show it here but it's set it on the
Google search right that's such an
arbitrary number 228 it's like you know
when you have $28.99 it's like oh it's
less than 30
maybe if I sign in I can see the price
that's why I definitely thought these
mannequins were people as I walked by
did you shoot him the first time now I
didn't know
damn you good steam protection can
anyone get early access I don't think so
I I want to say like part of it could
just be if you you actually purchase it
then you can probably get in I really
like these broken escalators man oh no
that's like it's an interesting are you
back to where you were
level design yeah back to the scene of
the crime Dane Johnson says while this
David guy seems really cool I feel like
that's one of your friends or something
like that I don't know I feel like
nobody comes in to say something like
that to a new person unless they're like
an actual person so dang good looking
out for your boy yeah I saw coming I was
like dude you're gonna take fall damage
this is not Assassin's Creed Odyssey
here I just I mean I gotta kill two but
we're gonna we're gonna gloss over that
because of my spectacular freefall there
Ishmael modele says this in battle RL
would be much better honestly I don't
think you want another battle rail I
think it's yes exactly I think that we
need a change
we're not change because this is not a
difference it's just that you need to
have other types of multiplayer shooters
I think then and the fact that
battlefield is out a month later it's
prime Pickens right now for World War
three and I mean if you really like
battle royale is there's so many options
already now like even from you know
third-party devs who were trying their
own spin on it like oh he's getting lit
up oh yeah so like the games out the
19th for whatever reason it doesn't have
the price here but when I did do the
Google search it said it was um $28 so
half of a normal retail game so that's
pretty cool
as future says no more be ours please
yeah I think outside of like battlefield
I don't really want to see any more I
feel like we've hit our critical mass
and like I don't think any really like
other new battle rails are gonna make it
but that's not gonna stop people from
trying
poorest place yeah he's such a buzzword
now - jolly cooperator it's more of a
battlefield than it is a call of duty if
you were to compare it to another FPS
game this game here absolutely
Olaf says this is battlefield without
the multi-million budget yeah but it's
still I don't know it still looks pretty
clean to me
and I took that as kind of a good thing
you know they're able to accomplish so
much much less budget I mean that's
really cool and that's a tank and a guy
so we're gonna see how that works early
on it's more like battlefield for all
those okay so you're trying to get to
like a heist like your teams are trying
to get to a score but mm-hmm
I don't know what that ends court maybe
5,000 possibly I mean usually with these
types of rounds time runs out before you
know you actually hit the the score mmm
cap right whoever has the most at that
time is gonna end up winning we're ahead
and I saw some people - actually maybe
that's just the plants just run down
mall psyching me out
these freakin mannequins you should hang
out with my squad instead of going solo
dolo all the time someone says to use
all your battle points oh yeah alright
that's that's a good point you have a
quadcopter a Reaper a Wolverine
oh he's China you're a risky man PC man
no bars held let's look at these well
battle points was talking about the ones
at the bottom I don't know how you
actually spend them but you see your
strikes like yeah you have strikes at
the bottom that you could actually call
in just so you have like a thousand
something battle points right now
interesting yeah which is interesting
because like are you even a the battle
points at the bottom well yeah I can
actually call them inlets oh yeah see
here you go cyborg here's another
vehicle you got a little like buggy hmm
this one's a nice one pretty fast when I
get closer I'm all called the I'm called
the quad cop and see what that does I
can see the key bind soon to the tide to
your numbers so I'm just gonna press
like a number eight or number six or
something and we'll see what goes now
Olaf says you can spot enemies are
through Jones is that a did someone call
in
another and we see the vehicle combat we
can try if he gets into a tank later
yeah if I can it is that the drone this
is the yeah well it's the quad copter
Jeremy so increased drilling hi and
there's a meter to second we go like 200
meters there was a guy to your bottom
right here somewhere right there is that
oh yeah get away from him there he is
she's trying to shoot you down yeah but
how do I back no don't get out of the
junk I'm flying the drone I don't even
know if that marker did someone or not
he didn't see me though we're not gonna
push up that bar maybe to get rid of it
you'd have to just use it up I'm just
self-destructed it well at least get
revenge for your drone how many players
per server it looks very empty I mean I
think right as of right now there just
aren't that many people playing such as
early access
got'em he's not good on me oh I love it
all right let's find well there's my
little buggy they love that John yeah he
did bought that your own I did yeah it
was self-destructing because I wanted to
try and push up on the guy but I want to
see where these tanks are I played a
tank earlier today it was actually
pretty interesting the tanks were really
fast in this game a lot faster than you
would expect them to be just waiting to
see what happens
the me drones for recon cool can you
play with the sniper
we tried that earlier and it didn't go
so hot I think so I'm not gonna tell
them to do that yeah unfortunately but
you can play a sniper people are hating
on the graphics I think it looks pretty
good at least when you compare it to
like what someone had mentioned earlier
insurgency I think this is better
personal any button yeah I don't think I
don't think the graphics are something
that I would be to you know I'm sad
about what we said at its tripping me
out
uh I mean it's at I think it's like at
115 or 104 it's pretty big okay I'm not
sure if it's rather at 105 yeah oh
you're so dead right no damn that's
pretty yeah that's the only other thing
I would say
buddy if naps were a bit smaller this
would probably appeal to more people
says my bebop blues hey I don't know I
think that you have to like consider
there's like other games like that and I
think they're not trying to be that kind
of game you can lean while ad icing yes
it's like rainbows if you can you can
eat without ABS off that right yeah no
reason
are the air vehicles based on points or
can you use them whenever um I think
they are based on points yeah at least
the that little plane that we saw flying
over that one I'm not too sure about I
tried spawning into it if I could and it
just wasn't working but everything else
in here at the bottom of my screen
you'll see there's like a flying eye
high explosive Elia these things all
have points attached to them thanks oh
no why is that an actual tank that's an
enemy vehicle yeah oh well you're the
heavy five good try whoa I was gonna say
it it feels like you're right you might
wait you might not make it in time I
feel like it's also because like I don't
think the games are like full on each
side so yeah I think I think you're
right Ambo
I mean like that's a decent amount of
people like whoa is that 12 or 15 people
vs. 12 B 12 yeah it's just about oh
that's a lot of people
nice oh yeah there's like cure three oh
yeah they are all trying to shoot me I
should have gone the goddamn sniper
class I do that's an interesting area T
they're kind of yeah yeah small studio
with that big budget game looks and
works well respect a lot of people are
hating on it comparing it to like I mean
I was the one that compared it to
battlefield I guess just because I don't
I guess I don't know there's been an
argument lately that you shouldn't have
to compare a game to something else but
it's the easiest way to convey something
to someone like when they're like oh
what kind of game is it well okay it's
very much like this game and they're
like okay but it's not necessarily fair
to the game either though right as I
feel like as mentioned it's way smaller
budget than a battlefield game way less
people working on it oh oh that's a that
was a trouble you hit your ally what I
did oh that was nothing about the meta
run-through team kills are possible here
and you can be like friendly fire and
totally mess someone up actually please
end up with the tank earlier on accident
it was not my intention
yeah it up hey guys dad shoot an RPG
close range let's go alright well he'll
met back then
Thank You friends this movie is not high
enough you want more fov we can do it I
think yeah now I'm gonna run right in
the middle of the area and then pull up
my settings yeah smart he'll never know
what hit him
can you try warframe maybe another day
just a lot going on and warframe though
and I don't think anyone in the office
has put that much time in it other than
maybe Alessandra I put some time in
warframe nice not nearly enough though
this is true Chris we are all entitled
internet trolls know that they can say
whatever they want and crap on a game
just because they can I wouldn't say
everyone let's say most of our chats
pretty respectable as I mentioned
yesterday I pretty much want to try to
like start to police the chat more I
think that it's okay to have criticisms
but like when you make comments that are
very specifically like you know you're
just trying to crap on a game just to
crap on a game then I don't know I think
that that stuff doesn't need to be in
here yeah it doesn't help wish I could
play and when she's get stuck after the
loading screen that what happened to you
yesterday when the server's morning yeah
but they actually the devs hit me up on
Twitter because I asked them about the
shippers and they said that it was just
that was part of the schedule it was
supposed to go up today yesterday
probably like install yesterday and then
Levi says the F of this fov is insane
when you sprain it feels like you're
looking through a fish eyes lens I guess
it didn't bother me that much yes but
but a lot of people have been talking
about fov l sciences but you're on
YouTube that's true that is true but
that doesn't mean that you can't like
create a community of people that want
to come watch hangout and have like a
you know yeah you can have a discussion
or debate it's fine you can be civil
about it though so this is a
dictatorship
I could totally watch out that guy no
you're right okay what's not have been
cuz he totally didn't shoot it just
didn't have a green marker on it freaked
me out for a second do you guys gonna
die here we're doomed
what's interests it's in the top 11
doesn't say what's interesting is they
don't show you the score but you got to
imagine that the that's what player list
is that's animal isn't it
you're the heavies let's go get my ammo
up you really need 400 this boy you
slowly regen too like you have three
segments of life right right that was
yeah the market was behind let's check
out this F of V real quick - before I
spawn in again you see what we're
looking at
field of view 120 trolling is stupid but
don't be sensitive bro I don't it's not
about that actually it's just that you
know cuz I'm here every day Bucky I see
a lot of stuff and some stuff is
whatever's and some stuff isn't so it's
more of me making a statement hoping
that like for the future things are
better
it's not about sensitivity I let a lot
of stuff slide to be honest if I was a
true dictator if I was ruling like you
know with an iron fist so to speak a lot
of people would be gone but then again
we might not have anyone so you know
when this is really some pious war I
don't think it's going to I think it's
yes the only yeah
I think it's come in a cup at least to
start maybe if it's big enough then just
running around with your ammo I was
raised on a vehicle action we've got the
majority of the caps right now but we're
still ahead so I guess our something
radiator I think this looks like a
battlefield game yes it does this is
gonna be a pretty common consensus for
yeah play tropical Eric actually we
actually had Tropico a couple like a
couple weeks ago and then it's just too
busy else I've never played a tropical
game neither have I so what's the most
recent one like tropical five six six
six was interesting how do you see the
future of this game well it lasts more
than a month that's the kind of the
question how I was saying pot right Huck
Suarez I think it's a good it'll have
definitely a good month for you know the
battlefield players are interested that
can't play battlefield for like another
month that might kind of hop in it works
out potentially just because it's also
not a full-price game it's according to
$28 it's also what Aaron said and so I'm
interested to see if this is able to
pull enough people away enough
battlefield players away from
battlefield but I I don't know
battlefields such a big franchise kind
of like Cod that I feel like we'll have
to see I don't know it's just hard for
me to believe that you know I haven't
played this game enough to be like oh I
think that it's gonna be a game changer
that's gonna get everyone away from them
I think that they're smart in that
they're coming on a month before
battlefield though that's for sure
named McNamee says I like having no
censorship in the chat because nobody
has a fear of being banned so they speak
their mind regardless of how an informer
Yawk that opinion yeah that's fine I
mean like you guys are allowed to say
what you want but you know obviously as
am Bolin giving has mentioned it's not
to be mean or bullying other people or
other people's opinions you know like we
can have a you know debate or discussion
and that's fine 97 was were you training
which one were you trying to get do you
wanna it's okay
well they already had it it all attract
the audience that isn't fun to be a five
and it's World War two ding that's true
Hey
oh that little pillar saved him yeah
that ice nice you can heal too if you
want you can just be my my health back
guide yeah let's throw a flashbang oh I
guess we won so yeah yeah cuz I was
gonna have you pull up the list I feel
like it was maybe half of the list was
full or something like yeah I just felt
like you could have had another like 15
oh yeah emotes Dewey you I don't know
that guy clearly is doing anyway I'm
looking alright everyone does look the
same everyone's got the same skin but
you know that's fine I mean like this
isn't what you're worried about I'm
surprised to even have one of these this
is very Call of Duty right here yeah
loving the diversity now you got a
little flex right there too
there's an interesting thing too with
that they had in the war map area before
you spawn in where if for anyone who's
played like fer honor you have like that
main sort of like tactical map where you
could send your troops or send supplies
or do whatever that game had to kind of
like work for your faction and in here
since before I started the game I chose
the West faction you can do the same
thing here so like right now actually
before I go in I can click on any of
these sections here so Warsaw Berlin
Moscow and when you click on them you
can donate your supplies and actually
okay so the world state updates about a
update itself in like less than a minute
Mazal wait for that yeah why not
and so right now it already seems like
on the global score it's not out yet
venom it's in early access and it'll be
in early access for others come the 19th
for $28 oh we're actually killing it in
the world zone it seems yeah where you
pick a faction okay yeah yeah totally
well I mean they just let you choose
between west or east and I chose West so
here we are
yeah just donate some supplies and help
my boys out Marco wants to know how are
the server's so far they're okay
sometimes when you when you spawn in
there's almost like no one and then
it'll build in pretty quick the game is
pretty good about filling in the server
me you I might not have had to wait more
than say four or five minutes before we
ended up having like a solid 10 v10
going on and then sometimes you're lucky
and you join into a server like and you
might just go right away and you'll have
24 verse 24 or something like that so
cool it's pretty interesting let's see
what happens here it's in progress and
it's gonna update again in an hour yeah
because the score itself just updated
everyone's West Side here
everyone's west it represents alright
alright joining in see what what kind of
a server we're gonna get now so is
America available for choice of factions
I don't think I saw isn't there like a
um let me see you can see a wiki yeah
well what you can do is
let me go to here why don't we show this
real quick so this is my oh sure
customization thing right here go full
game go ahead yeah so this is the
customization right here you can choose
your guy in fact I'm gonna show you guys
how he runs in its kind of kind of neat
I guess he doesn't this time but yeah
this is your character you can do
anything you want and in terms of
whoever asked if you could be like
America it's still west or east but you
can choose your flag every country's
here has an emblem and you're allowed to
do whatever you'd like even choose like
the whole European Union just kind of
funny I guess
oh and then you have a nice little
nickname to your sentence so mine is
zero Fox given pretty pretty I'm pretty
proud of that one actually we might be
able to go ball of steel just for humor
I think you can change a bit Oh your
taunts that's what it was so there email
it's like an insult people
it looks pretty uh yeah I'm insulted
that's for sure
you got a more threatening pose right
here there the Flex bodybuilding it
seems like it's more the same but it
kind of looks like it's both supposed to
be something else get your dance was
there any like muah was there any
customizations of the characters like
look appearance or anything
let's okay so you can spend some money
mm-hmm you can get face paint and
everything I wonder if you can like I
can make like a Middle Eastern character
to represent myself but I don't see it
right now but you definitely have a lot
of options for adding in sort of glasses
or camo you know face paint gloves and
different combat pants things like that
body paint and they all seem to have I
guess I bought that not yeah you had
sixteen hundred in your wallet up top
now yeah very good well these commando
stripes better be worth it yeah add that
in there so let's go
all right I want you hop back into a
quick gesture let's go black apostle
feels like they're gonna need a huge
step up if they want to be on par with
battlefields but I don't I mean I don't
know it's hard to say it part of it is
that it's yes it is an early access game
it's going to be an early access like
soft early access but it is 28 roughly
28 dollars I believe which is like half
the price of a battlefield game so you
kind of know what you're getting
yourself into obviously it's more like
double a title if you want to go instead
of triple-a and yeah it's a way smaller
studio so it's gonna be you know tougher
for them to you know maybe get to where
battlefield is but I think it still
looks and plays well from from what I've
seen so I think so
see if you oh is that tank assaulting a
to know that your tank does much a suite
oh man you guys look like you guys are
wrecking them oh you know why cuz you
joined mid-match its have real quick
again the vehicle - there's only two
minutes left - my service let me get
let's roll
we're all gonna navigate can you imagine
this like that the drivers test drive
tank site one ran said it might be
better to wait until it fully releases
in December possibly but if you want to
try it early and like I said it might
fill this void for some people you know
before Battlefield actually comes out
for a month but maybe you just play
battlefield 3 or 4 as some other people
were saying anything I reminded them
more of that and like no they're more
looking forward I guess yeah as it
should be very realistic
tank attack oh that was enemy tank the
one that was chasing that was coming up
yeah I mean I passed by a friendly tank
I don't think that was the yeah that's
pretty big
that's one's alright got 30 seconds
make sure your servers are full when
they send keys to show it off properly I
mean it's it's all too tough and
relative because you know it's all
timing and stuff like that I think if
you're gonna complain about not seeing
like only having a 20 be 20 versus like
a what 30 plus verse 30 I don't know I
get I guess if you want to see more
people it's fine but if I can go
third-person
and I guess we won that one boom those
getting two of you yeah I got my my one
tank kill I did my job for my team
that's fair
you're one-on-one right let's see if
anyone's gonna emote here the graph is
something that unlike the trailer though
yeah but that was for MU I mean a lot of
games don't look like their trailers
well it just depends on how different it
is I guess I would say that you know
most of that stuff is very highly
rendered stuff you know and then you
also have to realize we are a live
streaming game where the game you know
is gonna get compressed as it comes back
to you and then depending on your
internet bandwidth your PC etc it then
you know scales down again so it's it's
never gonna look a stream is never gonna
look 1 2 1 2 like that trailer little
like as it is because of things I just
said and also just because usually
that's stuff and that trailer is like
highly pre-rendered stuff right yeah I
agree with that this one seems like it's
a relatively new map because you know on
the there is a melee attacks laceration
as Mars the Mar said it is V yeah oh you
can slide yes okay what's up how are
y'all we're doing good how are you doing
we're doing really good
let me go in the tank actually let's do
this again let me change something here
real quick - because I noticed there was
a venom crap so I'm asking were you
given a key for free to play I mean yes
we were given a key it's correct I mean
we could have easily bought it - but I
mean I don't even if we bought it I
don't think we would have access to all
the xix though so we're just able to
show it off early right so
are you
this game needs a lot of improvements
look at squads for example in it
I will say I mean I would like yeah he's
Asian stuff yeah I'm sure I mean again
it's early access I think they want to
just get the game in players hands so
they can get a feel for it and hopefully
as as you mentioned get Gaius Julius
Caesar that some of these other
optimizations come in
you know it's play we'll see but yeah
like battlefield has a lot of good like
squad mechanic stuff totally being able
to spawn on them yeah and being able to
see them at all time so that's yeah
that's and I also feel like in the at
least when I played battlefield 5 data
it did feel like you know having those
different classes and there are no oh I
got so confused I thought my my buddy
did that for a second I thought you hit
him at first and like but then the whole
within the whole screen shook right and
it's like okay anything he's still there
yeah yeah he's doing he's doing the
smart thing which is but you got a guy
they're shooting RPGs as well he might
have backed off because of the RPGs
possibly so he starts having a point
though I can't even tell uh no I think
it's been contested okay
rush CV crashes they finally remembered
what this game reminds me of it's the
original homefront multiplayer but more
polish oh no another tanks you're right
Jim the shaking bakes okay he rolled
down the hill I think mildly
nerve-wracking back to your base to
repairing as too late for that but thank
you for the tip oh [ __ ]
Luke six says you can destroy tank
optics that's cool maybe that's what's
happening to me so it is a beta that's
what you just said I mean I I don't know
if it's actually a beta I got to go look
at the email to see if you want the
exact verbage I think we were just told
early access but right I guess
technically if you looked at Steam right
now the game becomes early access like
soft launch on the 19th mm-hmm we don't
check that I those words are all correct
let's see the invasion starts 10 19 2018
World War 3 will be available in early
access in a soft price model for just 28
USD yeah what it says
they are paid to play games lucky men's
this is correct dogs lucky men this is
very correct would you pay $28 for this
as it is asked ASB game London um for me
personally I see value in it
I don't play battlefield as much so I
probably personally wouldn't however if
I did play battlefield where I spend $28
on this probably just because it's it
has similarities you know I won't have
battlefield 5 anytime soon it's a newer
you know you got some newer people
starting to play the game as well so I
think it'd be worth trying I think the
other thing for me that would help if
almost I was a oh shoot your guy in the
back the other thing that would probably
help for me is if you know for whatever
reason if one of my friends or something
like that decided like hey I'm probably
gonna play too like then I probably
helped me out I probably like be more
incentivizing of course but to each
their own everyone has you know X amount
of dollars they can spend on games so
you know there's a lot that has either
come out recently or about to come out
you know you got Red Dead next week it's
a big one for a lot of people huge you
know Cod just came out
blackouts been pretty big so far I'm
curious to see if Cod you know continues
its success with blackout or if it just
becomes a thing that people slowly get
tired over or you know you know what I
mean like it's the first week so wow
melted we got shot four times not even
headshot I thought like for sure you got
headshot brush headshotted headshot it
can you jump yes okay it jumps kind of
weird but you can it's a lot shorter
than you'd think
Julius Caesar wants to know do you think
the map should be bigger and have
large-scale destruction to be
implemented is there any sort of
destruction in this
alpha / beta or whatever so far I
haven't seen any type of destruction
because as you had saw up with the tank
even when it ran into a wall it was kind
of like just making the metal kind of
like scraping effect not really
destroying it so I don't see that do I
think the map needs to be bigger again
as a Call of Duty player I don't think
the map needs to be bigger but you know
for the people that play battlefield
maybe you guys feel like it needs to be
bigger let's say it should be bigger if
we have if there's more access to
different types of vehicles right now I
see a like a buggy and a tank which is
fine but if there was you know if I
could climb in a jet right now or you
hit an allied how are the frames and
what GP you are using frames look fine
to me GPU is a 1070 yeah it's running at
60 right now 60 fps sergeant Turner
Ronda is looking at four to the 76
follow 76 beta show a mine that's soon
yes next week I think roughly around the
same is it the same day as Red Dead I
feel like I should hope not because that
is the 23rd or the 26th but let's find
out I could tell your honor yeah we had
a lot of really good coverage on
followed 76 on GameSpot calm for those
of you interested you can see some
really cool videos yeah there's been
play
there's like 4k as well on YouTube made
a video of a nuke falling for those of
you who like to see nukes yeah people
were saying that the like graphically it
didn't look very good yeah I could see
that that was just because of the
compression as the compression that we
need oh very good
right right I'm you know if you ask my
opinion on that I think that's kind of a
sacrifice that has to be made
considering the move to multiplayer I
want such a massive scale I personally
don't mind it too much I'll play devil's
advocate we we live in a
you're you know there are huge
multiplayer games with still pretty good
graphic fidelity but I don't know maybe
Anouk is like a whole different animal
well sure sure
so 76 beta is October 23rd so it's
actually before Red Dead if I have my
dates right yes
it's next Tuesday which means we'll
probably be streaming analysts and I
think that one's not nd8 I think the
first one was ND aid where you couldn't
do anything with it right the stress
test or whatever right is this
battlefield 4 no Kevin Lewis they
actually world war that I said it looked
like battlefield 4
I'm so glad someone brought that up
because I mean we're comparing it to
battlefield which is a good comparison
but very specifically battlefield 4
mm-hmm and now I feel really good about
myself let me heal first oh now I've got
the spine I like that one more really
yeah because you get to like I said you
get to be a selfish like player
see here Mikey after every yep oh he's
doing the lean yeah okay you should
leave I can do that too I'm not used to
it personally
yeah I need the door I don't really play
a lot of siege oh yeah once you check
your fov real quick because people are
curious I'm pretty sure it was like ouch
uh yeah it was pretty high is that 120
that's that's the max of the cam and go
um at the moment so then didn't change
it why you wants to lower it lower it go
to 100 yeah yeah people there you go go
to 100 or 99 right all right let's see
what we got
how does a SP gaming London wants to
know how does it feel firing the weapon
recoil control wise uh so for anyone
who's more into these types of shooters
I think you guys will be fine for me I'm
I can live with it but obviously it's
you know I'm losing a couple of
firefights because of that recoil this
is an auto rifle and I can't hold the
trigger down as much as I would like I
see a cod player yeah I'm a destiny
player actually I do cruise there's more
recoil now max that's not true they're
both more arcadey shooters right I don't
have that like uh uh oh wait you're like
getting like oh I'm getting jammed
jammed or something yeah maybe that's
really oh your guy was on the ground
prone wow I should I should shoot him oh
no you know what are you sniping down
the hallway prone that's hilarious
no you know what that's moderately
realistic you know like you didn't phase
through somebody right right
Oh watch out okay get behind those
sandbags get real tactical here let's go
shoot that mannequin I'm just came don't
do that okay
oh there is this is not really access
barely access starts on Friday so should
I call it early early access here I'll
have a David pull up the email later on
his phone so I can give you the verbatim
of exactly what the agra phone or is it
in AD your death I do pull up the email
that we got from the kind folks that
gave us our key let's see here so I can
give you the verbatim of what it
actually is I guess if you need that
clarity Jay Bane says I missed this
question let me see Jay BAM I apologize
I try to get through them you've also
gotten one of your messages deleted so I
don't know that's good here we go cool
that's the email right there all right
ah embargo and server blackout yeah
that's fine why early access that's fine
yep there's nothing in here that tells
me exactly uh you know it's like it says
no no it actually says early access key
at the very top okay it says World War
three early access key notes but you
know I mean that's basically the key
they gave us so yes for some people they
can't actually access it till Friday but
you know what cpu are you using s Marco
i7 8700 K later Shamari thanks for
stopping by hope you have a good day
does the FO be always increased when
running
I haven't even noticed maybe because I'm
just so you know taking him back by how
fast I'm sprinting actually Abdullah
wants to know how you feel about what do
you what are your feelings about the
hood the hood well
I mean it's there's nothing in
particular that seems out of the you
know out of place or anything like that
it seems like a really standard you know
shoot a hood nothing that's why me I do
like that I can see my battle points and
all that stuff at the bottom so I can
call things out but I mean I've
obviously still want some time trying to
figure out you had to like pull up a
menu to check it like someone no
actually you can see about what we had
to pull up a menu just to pick what you
wanted to use all right what does it
Reaper do does the quadcopter was just a
drone and now I don't think it's gonna
be in console maybe if it does really
well perhaps where as farm 51 support I
need help playing the game my screen is
stuck on a black screen with the cursor
that I don't know J beam sorry they said
that starts this Wednesday today they
gave me a key
yeah I mean you're in the same boat that
we were in I don't know have you tried
updating it I know that they've had a
couple of dates it took us till this
morning to actually get in there is
friendly-fire moose Ausmus ID I don't
know I'll try sorry if I miss aid and
I'm saying turn on the FPS counter we
can do that maybe next game we just turn
on the end video one yeah Dhiraj no not
as of now the environments are not
destructible I'm just talking this a PC
please help
does the game audio sound good I think
it sounds fine I don't think it's Oh
like mind-blowing to me right yeah it's
very standard although I will say that
the sprinting does sound a little kind
of weird in my head in my headphones and
that was before we started streaming too
so I had it pretty loud and it just it
didn't quite you know get my senses
where I wanted them to be but and
overall it's great
I think the most exciting that the game
has been especially just like what sound
design too is when you're just getting
completely barrage by tanks when you're
in look in the tank battle that type of
sometimes really really cool but yeah
gunplay sounds great
you know the hustle and bustle some of
the dialogues kind of cheesy you know
your characters really brash as
counterfeit world had said in chat
there's a message about black screens
and the main man you guys delete an HTML
file and then verify with steam so try
that if we get back out in the game we
can also check that out so you guys can
see it totally crime says they used
bought audio samples for guns by the way
no interesting I do not know that save
some time
a man oh it's only a one I can't really
be a passenger he didn't want you to be
I do that all the time that's my karma
right there what graphics settings are
using I didn't see they're all ultra
everything all ultra yeah everything
said it's at its highest key bum-rushing
opponent with a Ford slide I've only
seen the butt scoot I mean I could try
no I it's gonna that person's gotta be
pretty bad for you to be able to slide
up on him I feel like I want to heal oh
lordy prone heal maybe why not oh wow he
jason board he's just got rfp g'd
flashbang out
Oh behind me was indicator saying
someone was shooting me from the back
no I was in front of you there's like
two different spots like the one in
front of you and then the one on the the
ions I'm I'm curious I still don't know
what these are these planes like what do
they do
I don't know if someone called them in
or it looks like it's just giving
surveillance for potentially yeah I
don't know because they're making two
circles around the area so maybe it's
just like almost a UAV yeah possibly
look it out I'm gonna call in a partner
Palmer says it's not a bf map it's a
real Warsaw in Poland try to find CD
Projekt RED on the on the map is it on
Steam yes it'll be on Steam it's not
free though it'll be an early access on
Friday the 19th for $28 I believe that's
a grenade somewhere yeah almost but it
didn't he's not happy I wouldn't be
either like he's like I got this corner
why are you on this corner with that's
what I would be thinking guys depressed
see that guy I feel like was trying to
make one of those aggressive slide
attack tactics there and I just wanted
whoop this guy's dead - here we go like
these guys trying to get through here
are not gonna get through here without
like a flashbang or something
how many players are in your game right
now 21 verse 20 quite a good amount and
it's like you can get I don't know 30 or
40 potentially I don't think it's
actually see
there we go yeah but that's how battle
that's why I don't like Battlefield
games personally because right you have
to play more tactical yeah like you had
to play tactical here too so it's not a
game for people that want to rush around
although I feel like someone's gonna
flank you guys you guys are at this
point yeah yeah at some point someone's
gonna get smart enough to flank or go
for a different spot because you guys
have basically held down that choke
point and there's no no way in for them
you know right JB my I'd have to look at
the like main loading screen to tell you
which file to delete I do not know right
now I I do
wow that guy he was blended with City
though that was you're getting shot by
teammates I'm pretty sure like yes oh no
there's only one person that was your
teammate cuz 11 I would assume the red
is I don't ya know I mean that was I was
a weird one was it see what happens
well you guys are dominating them mm-hmm
does this game have any
microtransactions also is there any
pay2win I didn't see any I mean like I'm
sure there is any microtransactions it's
like the stuff we spent like money on in
terms of like the in-game currency was
like aesthetic changes to your character
and then there's also like emotes and
stuff like that so my guess is if
there's any type of microtransactions at
least at first clients is that it's it's
on those kind of like aesthetic like
changing face paint and stuff like that
or like you know your armor or something
like that like the look of it right now
in cosmetic and then emotes but again I
this isn't like the full full-on game
right so it's it's just early early
access since I can't call it just early
access it's hard to say if there's gonna
be any of that stuff so just be careful
can you guys show me how prone works
shown the butts couch you shown that
that's sick yeah they'll never get you
if you just back you know don't do it
okay back away all the way I'll do it
man
I take I take this bus keys very
seriously oh I'll do it Gary Shelton ask
what's the progression system like do
you unlock new guns um I would it's all
level for you something right maybe
because it is so early early I have them
there's like but yeah we'll find out
after this map there's another guy to
your left prone no that's like four
kills three I think maybe two and we're
just getting too excited yeah yeah
you're doing what I would do though
which is we're not leaning enough right
to be honest as the backseat driver here
I agree and Ville I think that the
sprint is a little too fast or it at
least looks really fast really fast but
I don't know that's something they could
tweak though easily
I feel like run speed see that was the
type of flank I was talking about so if
you want a running gun it's like you're
trying to get flanks and hope that like
the attention is on someone else right
and you went down like a long corridor
that they weren't even looking at so
yeah you know some people are trying to
run in to get capture point you know
cleaning up those people that are just
like chillin behind a car thinking
they're safe one I think those were
first Christmas tree - Noah tree
all these dead get your team
move was so close flash
oh you probably just like a wall or
something yeah jbn says there is a
weight system so I don't know I felt
like when you're heavy it didn't like
seem like you were running like that
slow either though yeah I don't know
maybe it affects your oh we definitely
need to play more tactical crime but we
play Arkady shooters it's not easy and
you know if anything we can just we can
point the blame to Aaron because he's
probably like one of the most tactical
shoot other than Ryan Schubert who is
also in the chat those two guys are real
tactical shooting fanatics where's you
got two guys here that just want to run
and God
yes have a mic
are you out of heels are you okay I have
one more
having somewhere in there this gun just
doesn't have the range I don't think
it's even worth this looks like a combo
between RAM row six and battlefield 4
anyone agree and yes says Jimmy Salgado
that actually that's kind of true
actually I just have like a little bit
of some of that stuff so you know any
chance you could turn your FPS display
on and list your PC specs last
gunfighter PC specs i7 8700 K 32 gigs of
RAM GTX 1070 we can turn the FPS next
time he dies potentially yeah wow that
that lean is way too aggressive says
Starscream another thing if that is the
case can be tweaked I feel like you know
obviously that's very flexible the thing
that you can do when you're in early
access is really tweaking you know maybe
come Friday there's gonna be like more
players and that'll give them more data
make more informed decisions nice
grenade I know right
another PvP shooter to flood the market
says renegade at least it's not a battle
royale though this is true so and in in
a year of battle Royales Oh
who that guy yeah so that's um caught
action right there yeah shoot his feet
oh yeah I got an assist for that one you
shoot that you see someone I don't kind
of makes a big plays
time to make some big plays let's go see
the main player Toller says ask Johnny
right now we had about 21 V 2020 V
20-ish but you can definitely have more
than that
so yeah games about by the farm 51
trying to see where we could show the
framerate if not try hitting old Z see
that no all didn't work I wonder if it's
because Joey changed it why don't you
play and I'll ask Joey yeah it's the
toggle no soldier yeah Nicholas Cameron
World War 3 confirmed in game not in
real life I kind of like the objective
systems as a whole in gaming it's not
just simple domination conquest and you
guys are honing them though well I've
got really good teammates wish I could
afford a ten seventy they're coming down
a little bit I feel like just because of
the that a new honey series or the 2000
series is out yeah yeah I try alt
delete' all tallit yeah there we go and
then go to settings and we go you guys
got your FPS counter now 64 players max
confirmed by farm 51 thanks Marcin I
think I capped it too at 60 so it can go
higher but okay well we can try on
capping it after I light them up I'm
gonna get lit up yeah let me uh let me
on cap it real quick see I think it's
under did it did you do is go under
advanced cramelock just abled just put
it all the way up to the top to some
case
and I think it still wants to stay at 60
interested not maybe it didn't take
effect because wonder if it's like a
reset thing yeah like you're still in
the game
mmm possibly I don't know we'll find out
yeah $700 here and I'll show ya yeah
everything in Australia is ridiculous
though as I have come to learn
we do have an Australian office and
Edmund Tran kind of like the lead
editorial / former like video producer
was telling me that you know stuffs
really expensive there yeah then I
started looking at stuff and I'm like
yep that's expensive are you at max
resolution I mean yes technically yes
Oh rested though like we're on a 1080p
monitor we're streaming 1080p so it's
not at 4k right you're asking we're
seeing a chat window during this deploy
stream yes you are is it is it
accessible only during that time main
communications - Mike no there's a chat
in the game - we've seen people say like
I'm stuck in a PC or stuff like that
yeah I think I had that set off actually
oh you turned it off yeah if I remember
correctly I thought we saw people
chatting in here though is what I'm
trying to say Oh like like just now yeah
yeah interesting maybe I'm mistaken
you're getting too excited over this
awesome game yeah bee sting bee sting
what about it disable vsync we can do
that later Oh true I think that's what
it what it probably is vsync so on so
it's trying to hug it - like 60fps
oh I see someone can I run up on him in
million and play a little relay one kale
when he killed we're about to find out
nope someone killed him before you God
buddy
I was so bummed I was gonna be fun
he's just taking over right now
not fast enough
all right let's turn off vsync Junior
Reyes this is only for PC currently
first impression says mark on lapses I
haven't played it so I mean just looking
at it and watching the game play again I
think it's it's doing what it needs to
do in terms of like coming out a month
before battlefield kind of giving you
some of those similarities and I think
that you know the people that are
interested will hop into the early
access come this Friday you know so many
dollars you know for the other folks
that are not interested they probably
won't you know yeah there you go there's
the FPS going up you have to hold you
have to hold the key dug right to lean
yeh like a toggle thing right right
right
it's cuny to lean left and right
respectively so I haven't seen any
toggles actually for Sprint even
although actually something that I was
doing while I was rushing earlier is if
you move forward while you're
controlling you can sprint while you're
crouching you buy armor helmet because
someone says you well a little slightly
he said you're not buying armor and
helmets buying an armor and helmet like
in-game I think you have armor helmet
right now though don't you I feel like I
should I see it in the bottom left as
like a white icon so I don't write I
think that that means you have it and
then if it Gray's out that then you lost
it or someone shot it off of you
possibly that'd be an interesting exceed
CUNY yeah right I actually show doctor
I'm not actually sure what the refresh
rate of this specific monitor is 60 you
know for a fact yeah yeah okay I checked
it earlier sleep
oh my god there was like so many people
lash banging the flashbang takes a while
askew that is sheer swag healing he did
get a couple on a road at one time it is
pretty tough though like I said if
you're if you're if you don't play
tactical shooters as much as it is tough
to kind of like modify your play style
to play that way I guess you can always
do the lame thing and just camp a point
oh no man something you'd be shocked it
works it does work because people get
salty when they die there and they come
back yeah yeah they want the revenge
mentality I'm like dude this is perfect
just like run behind them and do what
you did just now I'm just gonna tell
them I'm like right here honey
this is fun you're crazy really stay
please
someone said December possibly for full
huh release but I didn't see that myself
so early access starts Friday though
people want vsync back on now they do
they're seeing some tearing I know
people are all saying vsync on vsync on
vsync on so we'll give it back to them
so they're you know people what they
want and we'll get that people what they
want I can't wait till they say turn it
back on right I want to see that yes I
supposed to know if is this sim like
similar to our mo do you think it's sim
like um I wouldn't know I mean not I
wouldn't be able to compare it to ARMA
actually closest thing that I have to
reference it off of would be something
like insurgency or battlefield and
things like that I mean it does it is
kind of some like at least in terms of
your fast time to kill in the way that
you're moving around and interacting
the venom using stuff like that at least
in terms of weapon fire - you know my
weapon seems to be more of like this
close range to close medium range
definitely not a lot of long range
firefights that I'm winning
give him the 360 by the way this came
from game rate videos by the way in for
their belly or their neck if I remember
correctly the dev said that hit detects
hit detection system will be harsh all
soldiers here have armoured plates on
the chest Wow neck and belly that's
pretty neat actually that they they
implemented something like that so nice
massage sorry if I butchered your name's
gonna buy this game for sure he says
have you played RDR - yet no we have not
what is that game
what is this RDR - you speak of
counterfeit world says estimated out of
early access in 12 to 16 months it's on
the same page oh maybe actually do read
more oh there it is
proxy should've hit read read more
approximately how long will this game be
in early access how is the full version
plan to differ from the early October
early access version of World War three
is a solid foundation in the game to be
built upon throughout early access we
plan to polish the core game with bug
phases balance patches and content
updates including new maps units weapons
and game modes what's in the current
state of the early access version well
it's starting set of three Maps features
and contents with a goal to expand and
refine throughout the early access based
on community feedback right now our
focus main focus lies on refining and
balancing warzone mode all aspects of
the game are currently being balanced
live with the game still under constant
development so expect regular patches
and improvements until we reach will the
game be priced differently during and
after early access yes World War 3 will
be available for a cheaper price during
early access with the intent to raise
the price at full release this is to
reward and encourage those who invest in
World War 3 for the long term during
early access all future DLC content will
be available for free there you go I
should have heat hit read more a long
time ago um no destruction and I don't
believe there's campaign either nope not
that I've seen that's a hard question to
answer doctor goodness considering we
haven't been able to play battlefield 5
so I'm not gonna
be able to distinguish that for you it's
that way I played a little bit of the
beta but I have early access when it
starts up the screen goes black yes you
have to delete a certain HTML file
Junior I don't know which one that is
because we'd have to be in the main
screen for me to tell you which one that
is
Wow nice get my assistant helping my
teammates out I feel like you can I'm
gonna head there this is such an
aggressive lean house like firecrackers
I know right alright let's just check
some setting stuff and then we're
probably gonna call it a wrap and go
through some of the menu stuff - sassy
taunt there feel like if we gotten
another game it's gonna be like another
like 23 years it's gonna be a while
we're gonna go to the main screen in
here in a second so you guys can see
what you need to do as mentioned by farm
51
they're constantly updating it's even on
the main screen itself it's like hey we
just updated it uh you know texture fix
I think is what I read um you know make
sure you update or if you're getting
this error do this so we'll get there in
a second there's your is that your
actual personal rank yet so your private
right goes kind of slow yeah to be
honest you've gotta get to 40,000 here
first level this ain't no like COD where
you get to like level 3 in one before
yeah yeah
so here you go we're investigating some
you know black screen low try restarting
we're verifying deleting the ww3 HTML
folder and verify again they also did a
low tester bug has been resolved make
sure you update your game so try that
yeah but otherwise thank you David for
playing my pleasure have or early early
access I guess very early we'll just
call it that otherwise it comes out
Friday $28 as mentioned it seems like
it'll be cheaper now and then they plan
you know 12 to 16 months down the road
to make it a little bit more expensive
just to incentivize those that want to
kind of in
early can you use a controller I feel
like you wanna go back real quick I
think I feel like there was like a
setting for you to maybe do that but I
might be crazy you might be crazy might
be crazy quite crazy
yeah I don't see anything for
controllers unfortunately well anyways
come back tomorrow
forget about live 11:00 a.m. we will be
playing another game a little bit
earlier than expected
I know maybe maybe not though maybe cool
maybe like worldwide releases probably
like around the same time but we'll be
back tomorrow mean Alessandro thank you
to David again for playing and we'll
catch you next time for more World War 3
like gameplay impressions thoughts um
possibly guys and things like that stay
tuned to games.com have a happy
Wednesday peace